so we're getting this perfect storm of
incompetence arrogance and desperation
to reopen the economy from Republicans
that's leading to really really
dangerous stuff and as you know or you
may know Donald Trump has been talking
about chloroquine with azithromycin as a
possible game-changing treatment or cure
for coronavirus and as I've told you
there are some serious side-effects
it needs study it has potential but some
guy in Arizona has now died after taking
chloroquine phosphate which is a
fishtank cleaning product related to the
ingredient in the medication it's not
the medication I'll talk to you about
that in a little bit but we now have Fox
News propagandist Sean Hannity who's
recommending a cocktail of things as a
sort of prophylactic to prevent
coronavirus as much as he seems to be
saying it also cures it and it's
incredibly irresponsible and dangerous
for two reasons number one when you
imply there's a prophylactic for
coronavirus which there currently is not
but there's these you know vague
speculation based on very little data
this can get people to behave very
irresponsibly and think they don't have
to do physical distancing number two
you're actually suggesting something
that can be dangerous for people to take
check this out Sean Hannity did it
during an interview with vice president
Mike Pence last night mr. vice president
I'm holding up a letter and I'm gonna
read from it in a second from a doctor
than New York area and if I may read
from it he has now worked with his his
associates and he has a regimen
hydroxychloroquine 200 milligrams twice
a day five days as it throw myosin 500
milligrams once a day five days cinq
sulfate 220 milligrams once a day for
five days this is what he has seen him
and his team have now treated
approximately 350 patients and Kairos
Joel is an area of New York that was hit
particularly hard and another hundred
and fifty patients in other New York
areas his results we have had zero
deaths zero hospitalizations zero
intubations so he refers to a doctor in
the New York area who gave this
so-called regimen
and treated 350 people in curious Joel
and another 150 elsewhere in New York
with zero deaths so before we even look
at the regimen bear in mind first of all
curious joel is a Hasidic Jewish
community an hour north of New York City
the fact that a doctor had 350 quote
patients in curious Joel which has a
total population of 24,000 to me that
suggests if this is even true it's
overwhelmingly young people that they
are quote testing this on why do I say
that Hasidic Jews have many kids they
have a lot of kids so when I hear this
was tested on 350 people in curious Joel
I think these are all kids and young
people that would do fine anyway plus
it's not even clear whether this was
being tested prophylactically he may be
saying a doctor and curious Joel gave
this to 350 people who didn't even have
coronavirus and they've not since gotten
coronavirus that would be very very
meaningless and lastly no deaths out of
350 patients is meaningless when you're
dealing with a likely real death rate of
under 1% anyway so this is all very
useless but when you look at the
so-called regimen hydroxychloroquine 200
milligrams twice a day five days as the
throw Meissen a once a day five days
sink once a day five days
dink sulfate is just a zinc supplement
there are a few people who say zinc is
one of the few supplements that might
actually help prevent the common cold
even though we're not aware of any
actual common cold treatment one third
of common colds are corona viruses of
sorts most of the benefit of taking zinc
seems to be in people who are deficient
in zinc in their diet if you're getting
enough zinc from your diet it's unclear
that there's much or any benefit from
zinc then you've got hydroxychloroquine
which is the drug that you can't just
get it and unfortunately people are
stupidly thinking that the fish tank
cleaner with a similar ingredient is the
medication somebody already died in
Arizona from taking that and then of
course you've got a zoo throw Meissen
which is an antibiotic taking
antibiotics unnecessarily isn't good for
you you also need a prescription for
that so this is just crazy
and irresponsible for Sean Hannity to be
talking about on Fox News as if it's
anything at all
never mind something that prevents or
cures coronavirus Sean Hannity also
saying last week on his radio show that
he believes vaping may have a protective
effect in the lungs against coronavirus
also no evidence of that no no good
evidence of that very dangerous stuff
coming from Sean Hannity on Fox News and
this coming during an interview with
Vice President Mike Pence I want to give
a quick shout out to one of our sponsors
VIN Charo watches they're giving my
audience 15% off your entire order when
you go to david pakman.com slash watch
maybe you don't usually wear a watch and
you've been thinking about looking for
one to elevate your look or you've been
thinking about replacing the one you
have
check out VIN Charo it's an American
company all of their watches are built
in small batches from high-end materials
they look amazing and they look like
something you'd spend a lot of money on
but ever even taro watch ranges from a
hundred and fifty to three hundred
dollars I went on their website and
picked out the Kyros in white and silver
really love the look the combination of
the white face and the beige band really
loved this one they also sent me the
Kairos limited release gold reserve set
totally different style this one would
make a fantastic gift for a couple
people I can think of in my family any
time you see me wearing a watch on the
show I'm wearing a Ventura watch go
through their collection I know you'll
find something you like and you'll get
15% off when you go to david pakman.com
slash watch